La diagonalisation quantique de Krylov, ou KQD en abrégé, désigne la résolution d'un problème de valeurs
propres matricielles en projetant la matrice dans un sous-espace préparé sur un ordinateur quantique, conformément à la méthode de Krylov,
une approche puissante issue de l'algèbre linéaire classique. Tout au long de cette vidéo, nous allons explorer à quoi sert la méthode de Krylov
et comment et quand la mettre en œuvre sur des ordinateurs quantiques.
Alors, qu'est-ce que la méthode de Krylov ? Supposons que nous ayons une matrice H liée à un problème scientifique ou professionnel, avec n lignes et n
colonnes. Nous nous intéressons à la plus petite valeur propre e 0 et au vecteur propre correspondant, noté psi 0. Définissons un
vecteur initial v, qui peut être motivé par la structure de H ou être entièrement aléatoire. Le sous-espace de Krylov
d'ordre r, que l'on note k r, est généré en appliquant H sur ce
vecteur initial r moins une fois, en ajoutant le résultat de chaque application successive de H
à l'ensemble des vecteurs générateurs — c'est-à-dire que kr est l'espace engendré par les vecteurs v,
Hv, H carré, et ainsi de suite. Ces vecteurs ne seront pas orthogonaux en général.
Classiquement, on effectue souvent un processus d'orthogonalisation très similaire à la procédure de Gram-Schmidt. On commence
par normaliser le vecteur initial V et on appelle le résultat V 0. Ensuite, pour le vecteur suivant HV, on soustrait sa
projection sur V 0 pour rendre les deux vecteurs orthogonaux. On normalise ensuite le résultat. On continue ainsi,
en appliquant à nouveau H et en rendant le résultat orthogonal à tous les vecteurs déjà ajoutés, jusqu'à avoir construit R
vecteurs orthonormaux nécessaires pour engendrer le sous-espace de Krylov de dimension R.
Une fois ce sous-espace obtenu, on y projette notre matrice et on diagonalise la matrice projetée, plus petite. Il existe
des subtilités et des extensions, mais c'est là l'essence de la méthode de Krylov dans sa forme la plus simple.
Pour mieux comprendre son fonctionnement, regardons un exemple trivial. Si H est cette matrice et que V est choisi comme ce
vecteur, on commencerait par normaliser V. Pour générer le deuxième vecteur du sous-espace de Krylov, on applique
une fois H sur notre vecteur initial, puis on rend ce résultat orthogonal à V 0.
Un peu de calcul donne ceci pour V1.
Ce n'est pas utile pour des matrices aussi petites, et on ne s'arrêterait généralement pas à une dimension de Krylov de deux. Mais si l'on devait
projeter H sur notre nouvel espace de Krylov K2, on le ferait à l'aide d'une matrice V
dont chaque colonne est un vecteur de Krylov et dont la transposée conjuguée a les vecteurs de Krylov en lignes. On obtiendrait alors
cette matrice.
Cette matrice a techniquement une dimension inférieure à celle de notre matrice d'origine. Évidemment, cette réduction n'est pas utile à cette
échelle. Cette méthode est destinée à réduire des matrices comptant des milliers, voire des millions de lignes et de colonnes,
à seulement quelques-unes. Alors pourquoi les méthodes de Krylov sont-elles utiles ? Il s'avère que cette simple prescription
d'action d'opérateur est souvent le moyen le plus efficace d'approcher l'état de plus basse valeur propre, ou état fondamental, d'un opérateur matriciel.
Rendons cela un peu plus explicite, même si nous laisserons la preuve complète au texte d'accompagnement. Nous souhaitons
résoudre un problème de la forme : H agissant sur le vecteur x nous donne une constante fois le vecteur x. Commençons avec une
estimation de notre vecteur propre x0. C'est juste une solution approchée. Elle comporte une erreur que l'on appelle e 0. On souhaite
mettre à jour cette estimation, qu'on appellera x1, en espérant améliorer notre approximation. On peut l'exprimer comme
le x0 original plus une correction p 0 encore à déterminer. On peut
répéter ce processus de façon itérative, en ajoutant de plus en plus de vecteurs de correction pi.
Évidemment, on veut réduire notre erreur, mais ce n'est pas seulement l'état qui compte. L'action de H sur cet état nous importe aussi.
Donc la quantité que l'on veut vraiment minimiser est la norme-H de cette erreur, c'est-à-dire la norme de
l'action de H sur cette erreur.
On voit maintenant qu'il s'agit d'une expression impliquant p 0, et on peut se demander quels choix de p minimisent
le plus efficacement cette norme-H de l'erreur. Dans quel espace doit-on chercher la correction ? Sous certaines
conditions — comme lorsque H est symétrique et définie positive — choisir les r premières corrections dans kr s'avère
optimal. En termes simples, il faut un moyen de préparer un bon sous-espace sur lequel
projeter notre Hamiltonien. Et dans de nombreux cas, le sous-espace de Krylov est l'espace engendré par les vecteurs des corrections
les plus efficaces à notre estimation initiale.
Pour une preuve rigoureuse, consulte le texte accompagnant cette vidéo.
Tout ce qu'on a décrit jusqu'ici peut être fait classiquement. Alors, comment et quand utiliserions-nous un ordinateur quantique ?
Pour des matrices très grandes, la méthode de Krylov peut nécessiter de longs temps de calcul et de grandes quantités de mémoire. Le temps
nécessaire pour l'opération matricielle de H sur V croît comme N au carré dans le pire des cas.
Et cela est fait pour chaque vecteur que l'on souhaite inclure dans notre sous-espace. La dimension R du sous-espace n'est généralement pas une fraction significative
de N et croît souvent comme le logarithme de N. Donc la génération de tous les vecteurs croît
comme l'ordre N^2 log N.
Bien qu'il existe d'autres étapes comme l'orthogonalisation, c'est là le facteur d'échelle dominant à garder à l'esprit.
L'informatique quantique nous permet de changer quels attributs du problème déterminent le facteur d'échelle du temps et des ressources
nécessaires. Au lieu d'une dépendance à la taille matricielle n de manière générale, on verra des choses comme le nombre de shots et
le nombre de termes de Pauli non commutatifs qui composent un Hamiltonien.
Voyons comment ça marche.
Rappelle-toi que l'opérateur qui fait évoluer temporellement un état quantique est l'exponentielle de iH sur h barre. Et il est
très courant, surtout en informatique quantique, d'omettre le h barre dans la notation.
Une façon de comprendre et même de réaliser une telle fonction exponentielle d'un opérateur est d'examiner son développement en série
de Taylor. Remarque que cette opération appliquée à un vecteur initial V donne une somme de termes
avec des puissances croissantes de H appliquées à l'état initial. On dirait qu'on peut simplement construire notre sous-espace de Krylov en faisant évoluer
temporellement notre état initial estimé. Et c'est presque vrai. La nuance réside dans
la réalisation de l'évolution temporelle sur un vrai ordinateur quantique. Beaucoup de termes du Hamiltonien ne commutent pas entre
eux. Ainsi, si certains opérateurs exponentiels simples comme e à la puissance moins i z correspondent à des
circuits simples, les hamiltoniens généraux ne le font pas, et comme ils contiennent des termes non commutatifs,
on ne peut pas simplement décomposer l'exponentielle en un produit de termes simples comme on le ferait avec des nombres. Donc
ce n'est pas trivial, mais c'est un processus bien étudié en informatique quantique. On effectue l'évolution temporelle
sur des ordinateurs quantiques à l'aide d'un processus appelé trotterisation, qui est en soi un sujet riche. Mais à très haut niveau,
en découpant l'évolution temporelle en petites étapes, disons M étapes, on limite les effets de la non-commutativité des
termes. Appelons le sous-espace de Krylov d'ordre r que nous avons généré dans le contexte classique en utilisant des puissances de H
directement le sous-espace de Krylov des puissances kpr.
Nous allons maintenant générer un espace similaire à l'aide de l'opérateur d'évolution temporelle unitaire u donné par l'exponentielle de iHt.
Nous appellerons cela le sous-espace de Krylov unitaire kur.
Le sous-espace de Krylov des puissances kpr que nous utilisons classiquement ne peut pas être généré directement sur un ordinateur quantique car H n'est
pas un opérateur unitaire. L'utilisation du sous-espace de Krylov unitaire peut être montrée comme donnant des garanties de convergence similaires
à celles du sous-espace de Krylov des puissances.
Plus précisément, l'erreur sur l'état fondamental converge efficacement tant que l'état initial V a un chevauchement avec
le vrai état fondamental qui ne s'annule pas de façon exponentielle, et tant qu'il y a un écart suffisant entre les valeurs
propres. Ici, les puissances de u deviennent différents pas de temps. La k-ième puissance de u correspond à une avance
en temps de k * dt.
On peut étiqueter l'élément du sous-espace ayant évolué temporellement pour un temps total kdt comme s indice k. On peut projeter notre
Hamiltonien H sur le sous-espace de Krylov unitaire kur. En d'autres termes, on
calcule chaque élément de matrice de H dans la base kur. Nous appellerons
cette matrice projetée H tilde. Les éléments de matrice de H tilde sont donnés par ces valeurs d'attente qui peuvent être
estimées à l'aide de l'ordinateur quantique.
Garde à l'esprit que H peut s'écrire comme une somme d'opérateurs de Pauli sur différents qubits, et que tous les opérateurs de Pauli
ne peuvent pas être mesurés simultanément. On peut regrouper les termes de Pauli en groupes de termes commutatifs et mesurer tous
ceux-là en même temps. Mais il nous faudra peut-être de nombreux groupes pour couvrir tous les termes. Ainsi, le nombre de groupes commutatifs distincts en
lesquels les termes peuvent être partitionnés, ngcp, devient important. Si on utilise un sous-espace de Krylov unitaire de dimension r, la
matrice résultante aura des dimensions r * r. Si r est bien inférieur à n, on a
fait des progrès utiles, et typiquement r est bien inférieur à 100, ce qui signifie qu'on peut facilement diagonaliser cela sur un ordinateur classique.
Mais rappelle-toi que s n et s m ne seront généralement pas orthogonaux. Il est
parfois possible de diagonaliser une matrice dans une base non orthogonale. Mais il y a des raisons numériques et physiques
pour commencer par passer à une base orthogonale. On résout donc un problème généralisé de valeurs propres en utilisant la matrice de Gram S.
L'élément mn de la matrice de Gram est donné par le produit scalaire de s m sur s n.
Les éléments de H tilde et de S sont tous calculés à l'aide d'un test de Hadamard.
Le problème généralisé de valeurs propres devient alors celui-ci.
Comme indiqué plus haut, la dimension R du sous-espace de Krylov unitaire est exponentiellement plus petite que notre
dimension matricielle initiale N. Ce problème de valeurs propres est donc simple à résoudre classiquement.
Pour récapituler : on commence avec un état de référence, puis on le fait évoluer pour différentes durées afin de générer le
sous-espace de Krylov unitaire. On projette notre Hamiltonien sur ce sous-espace et on estime aussi les chevauchements des
vecteurs du sous-espace. Enfin, on résout classiquement le problème généralisé de valeurs propres de dimension réduite. Comparons ce qui
détermine les coûts de calcul pour utiliser la technique de Krylov classiquement et quantiquement. On a esquissé cela
pour la version classique, et il n'y a pas d'analogues parfaits entre les approches classique et quantique pour toutes les étapes. Mais ce tableau rassemble
quelques facteurs d'échelle de différentes étapes à prendre en compte. Rappelle-toi que les hamiltoniens ont généralement des termes qui ne peuvent pas être mesurés simultanément car ils ne
commutent pas. On regroupe les termes du Hamiltonien en groupes d'opérateurs de Pauli commutatifs pouvant tous être mesurés simultanément, et on peut avoir besoin de nombreux
groupes pour couvrir tous les termes qui ne commutent pas. Pour construire H tilde sur un ordinateur quantique, il faut
des mesures séparées pour chaque groupe de chaînes de Pauli commutatives du Hamiltonien. Et chacun nécessite de nombreux shots. On doit faire cela pour R
au carré éléments de matrice différents correspondant à R au carré combinaisons de différents facteurs d'évolution temporelle. Il existe
parfois des moyens de réduire cela. Mais dans ce traitement approximatif, le temps nécessaire croît à peu près comme
le nombre de shots fois le nombre de groupes de termes de Pauli commutatifs fois r au carré.
Les éléments de S doivent être estimés, ce qui croît comme le nombre de shots
au cube. On voit que la diagonalisation quantique de Krylov peut être utile dans les cas où le nombre de groupes de Pauli commutatifs
dans le Hamiltonien est relativement faible.
Cette dépendance d'échelle suggère certaines applications où la méthode de Krylov peut être utile et d'autres où elle ne le sera probablement
pas. Certains hamiltoniens ont une complexité élevée lorsqu'ils sont mappés sur des qubits, impliquant de nombreuses chaînes de Pauli non commutatives
qui ne peuvent pas facilement être partitionnées en quelques groupes commutatifs.
C'est souvent le cas pour les problèmes de chimie quantique. Par exemple, cette complexité présente deux défis principaux pour
les ordinateurs quantiques à court terme. Premièrement, l'estimation de chaque élément de H tilde devient coûteuse en calcul à cause du
grand nombre de termes. Deuxièmement, les circuits de Trotter requis deviennent trop profonds. Ces deux points
seront moins problématiques lorsque les ordinateurs quantiques atteindront la tolérance aux fautes, mais ils doivent être pris en compte à court terme. Même les systèmes avec des mappings plus simples
que ceux de la chimie quantique peuvent connaître les mêmes obstacles si les hamiltoniens ont trop de termes non commutatifs.
La méthode de Krylov est la plus utile lorsque le Hamiltonien peut être partitionné en relativement peu de groupes de Pauli commutatifs
et lorsque H est facile à implémenter dans des circuits de Trotter. Ces deux conditions sont satisfaites, par exemple,
pour de nombreux modèles de réseau d'intérêt en physique. KQD est particulièrement utile si l'on sait très peu de choses sur l'état fondamental.
Cela découle de ses garanties de convergence inhérentes et de son applicabilité dans des scénarios où
les méthodes alternatives sont intenables faute de connaissances suffisantes sur l'état fondamental.
Bien que KQD soit un outil puissant, les aspects chronophages du protocole — en particulier l'estimation de chaque
élément du Hamiltonien projeté et le chevauchement des états de Krylov — représentent des possibilités d'amélioration. Une
approche alternative consiste à approximer l'état de Krylov à l'aide de circuits de Trotter, puis à échantillonner
l'état approximé pour obtenir une projection sur la base computationnelle, puis à projeter H sur le sous-espace
engendré par ces états de la base computationnelle.
Dans les cas où elle est applicable, cette méthodologie connue sous le nom de diagonalisation quantique de Krylov par échantillonnage SKQD
offre potentiellement des réductions significatives en temps et en ressources par rapport au KQD traditionnel.
L'intégration des techniques de sous-espace de Krylov avec les méthodes d'échantillonnage dans SKQD représente une frontière passionnante dans
les algorithmes quantiques.